I like being the big spoon man I'm
old-school yeah feel real weird being
the little spoon you know yeah I like
being a moan silverware drawer really we
need to give a pelham message yeah we
have a cultural cultural statement cat
if you can but it is every time I see
Jim hell I feel like he just closed one
of those big barbecue nope nobody's
getting the secret recipe they call me
chef sick-ass ratatouille three well how
the hell are you who calls you chef
you're always starving do you be a great
chef yet the look at the attitude for ya
get your life together dude yeah yeah I
do good smoker though you got one of
those Green Egg barbecue joints I can't
get a small I live in a room middle dude
be a Native American be an American dude
dude dude the brisket I like they do on
a can afraid catch a lizard Bay that
thing under the sand let the Sun [ __ ]
cook him
a 24-hour brisket there it's at land
jerky dude you get a big lizard put that
bastard under the sand yeah blindfold it
yep put it under the sand don't tell it
where it is so a couple mangos in their
little flavor yeah baby lizard so like
marinade oh yeah dude that's the Lord's
crock-pot brah mother earth run he can
afraid rose son yeah lizard roast okay
got you a thick ass iguana toss some
pineapples in there let him [ __ ] die
in the sand dude yes snaggle wanna baby
why you shredder one got here starving
when God's just providing you with
delectables you're out of your mind
marriage it was a [ __ ] rat to the sky
time out that nice clean pigeon put that
[ __ ] thing oh yeah baby get you that
a little bastard brought that little
seed thought brother they always did you
see them up there looking fish see
either way I just care I fed a damn
button one time a button fell off my
shirt and I fed it to that bastard
they'll eat anything bro whatever ya
doodle [ __ ] a cuff link brother then and
things will eat anything pigeon they
don't care bro oh you can see people
interrogating them online they never
tell where they're from tell you my
homegirl thinks to their robots made by
the government well and that sounds like
somebody you didn't probably go to a lot
of school yeah be on medication like
like look at him just spying on us [ __ ]
you're at the park yeah [ __ ] brought
bread these ducks ain't fooling nobody
oh look at this little narc over here
you like yeah yo he's always looking for
him when I'm doing coke
[Laughter]
he just curious he just being curious
people wild man people are while and
it's a scary it's I don't know if it's a
scary time to be alive but it feels like
we're just going through [ __ ] we'll get
through it
my Birds actually gonna shoot drones
wait shouts out to Kylie man Will Smith
to the animation movie of a bird it was
a spy my son loved it [ __ ] yeah really
was a recent yeah recent great movie
wasn't what's the call I forget what's
that Will Smith bird movies inside spies
like us spies in disguise oh it's good
yeah it's really good I'm just now
watching Disney [ __ ] yeah man what do
you been what are you then watch the
Nutella Tommy I never got it to stuff
like that I don't watch a lot of bro you
do need to make a damn barbecue sauce
sorry to interrupt you but I my god
every time you start talking I wanna buy
just sell ya buy a couple gallons of
that [ __ ] hell's barbecue so we call it
you know what I was on The Ultimate
Fighter
Kimbo Slice used to be you'd make all
our food used to barbecue you yeah the
best barbecue ever room and he went let
us watch his barbecue the way made his
barbecue sauce was the best and then me
and him eating meat him became close
friends by the end of the season I was
like you gotta show me the barbecue
sauce before I go back home he's alright
looked around and then all he would do
is grab like that you know the
masterpiece barbecue oh yeah they dumped
a bunch of honey in it and a little bit
of mustard mix it all up they put it on
the steaks and the chicken I said dude I
have no money neither do you but best
and you should open a barbecue joint
called slices
ooh Kimbo slices bro just slices young
him with a gold grill on the front Oh
ribbon his mouth oh what a rib I need to
do something I'm [ __ ] around you need
to do
Kimbo taught me how to make a great
barbecue sauce they showed me a favor
a knife fight he said you give you give
me a four I'm dog
he was look at my forum it looked like
it cut it up it looked like a shark's no
that's cool was that from because you
give them that then ain't [ __ ] then they
go good you get on there yeah that's
information I need it really is time out
with that go ahead try and cut me
nothing that's nothing boy
nothing born and you've pulled that
sword out Kimble essence dog dude
somebody that's obviously if you bro you
definitely bring a sword to a slice
fight bro Kimbo Slice is dude slices
bars joining the Dade County Miami papi
what would we call Chappelle's barbecue
sauce though we need you to apron first
bro
yeah you got to get the bear you got to
get the bare necessities you know so
would your barbecue joint just play like
oasis today he's gonna be today
you know like dude on the nickel huh
people hate on the nickel then you know
much money then boys money I get that
that's fine let's go to this video let's
go to there's a video an amazing video
of Nickelback playing the Dallas Super
Bowl
no that was Creed Creed or time line
across Creed is basically that go back
to people who aren't sure which was
which yeah it's very good run it's the
way he's flying across the car
this is homo it's really homoerotic well
we no offense if anybody's homosexual
buddy didn't he kill himself though
didn't he die he tried they lead singer
Creek creature i jumping off a balcony
at any hotel but he thought why don't ya
but he should have closed him cuz he
live
it's a Wonderful Life yeah he tried to
he tried killed himself not here on
people hate on these guys but they're do
all they were amazing it was almost the
first CD I ever bought instead I bought
in LA country a little forward they
finally you see some tumbler yeah it
start here why is the girl think was
about to get a raise now he's losing
tell the industry is one bad Creed video
and that's you know you're fired
oh this is it yeah this huh she bells
playing this is his wedding I'm sure I
Betty it comes about when you get
married
I don't want it I want the Gallagher
brothers there maybe get Godsmack I like
Godsmack people run to you see some guys
that are tumble down and from the
ceiling yeah you start like it's him
wires into the performance yeah here we
go
he just started is there anything where
we go he wears in Super Ball
performances he's doing nothing worse in
this one
why do wearing adidas track pants why
not cuz he's a billionaire I don't think
any billion is jumping off a [ __ ]
motel in Miami because he hates his life
you feel me but first of all you can't
even kill yourself on a motel do they're
three stories high
he kind of has some pipes on him though
huh yeah yeah yeah where you'll hate
this guy's I like him I thought you guys
me I like Kim I like let's go back you
don't like you go back you would like
what's wrong with Nickelback make sure
you pronounce it fully - dude you guys
are making me feel a little racist but
look at this [ __ ] what is this bro
so the choir you got the choir but then
you got these men they got really
assailants these are almost like gay men
trying to get in the building the whole
thing is just a [ __ ] show no just a [ __ ]
show you see those men
tumblin you see there's a girl from
clues I'm not sure
hey zip is it bad this looks kind of
awesome
I know you guys trying to clown it looks
like a pretty good show well dick if I'm
not a part of the men repelling there
you go the men repelling from the
ceiling they show him for a half second
each time I think he does it too though
doesn't he Thea repelling yeah I thought
he was flying across the - I mean look
at this dude O'Brien before his Lydia
died you're right man I'm sorry Nate
that wasn't a bad performance man really
dude you feel I know people want to hate
you you want to go through the the
bangers Nickelback head go ahead dude
they had what'd you say would you go
back know what I saw them oh man
Nickelback were they from Canada oh wow
this is shout-out Canada remind me
oh yes I get it if people like something
like that's that's fine like it's not my
nickel washing not a poor masculine okay
I know you are beyond me
it's about hide and seek it nothing
about hiding it wait what about YouTube
super catchy yeah are you been modeling
you look at their mind what say took the
glasses off Wow
bring in a tan tan - where'd you go
Mexico get too close to the grill at
that combo what you think a bunch of
sake and [ __ ] warm your face up on
the grill yeah you sit you sit - cuz
they got the Benihana dark yeah you like
dark wood you're fishing it Balboa
Island
oh yeah yeah it's like Newport Beach
area when were you there chin this past
weekend I was there time oh really yeah
no way I was in Laguna with the fam
you're further down south in I think I
think Bobo's closer oh and so would you
guys do over there we should went
fishing on the dock really yeah there's
a little dock that uh one of my friends
Steven he knows it's like kind of a
private dock or something or just like
an unknown dock yeah
would you get spotted bay bass oh I got
some yeah I think it's spotted babe ass
out of a saltwater frickin that little
salt baby slap that thing across the
head and killer no they weren't big
enough that'll be like 14 inches I think
what a pedophile to be some kind of
pervert not big a plus you don't need
spotted bay bass no you could have a
little and be a [ __ ] do you have a make
up you could lick a fin do ya get a damn
no I love eating fins when they're fried
they're like potato chips disgusting
they're amazing
we shook on the eyes - if it's cooked
I'll eat some I just suck the eyes out
in his raw know yourself it's cooked all
you did this [ __ ]
thanks there dude you see when those
grouper eyes about the size of both of
our gigantic yeah just [ __ ] poke at
it we used to play I'm where we should
play marbles with them when I was young
we played with fish eyes hardened movie
a hardened bag of fish eyes dude play
all day
did they have marbles when you were
kidding me at school I never got into
the mark we played it man we played
almost every day did they call cat eyes
some of them yeah dad cat ah
steelies ham and eggs dude I was a big
pot guy doesn't say these guys do pause
that slammer boom give me your [ __ ] dog
little hogs little warheads man wash it
down with Capri Sun sticky fingers you
do bollocks huh no do we went out there
like freakin men played with fish eyes
with our thumbs and played a real game
where you freaking beat somebody and hit
him with that hard little ball marbles
you idiots yeah then the part because I
had the big the slammer the slavery oh
that was like the yeah yeah no okay no
matter how tough you why cause I was
playing pogs listen to Nickelback I want
to see that I want to eat a batch of
that carp you caught it yeah you got to
bring that carp in next time and bring
us a cut of that car quickly [ __ ]
yeah bring some [ __ ] sashimi is Ginny
yeah doing all this [ __ ] audition all
the time yeah sashimi sashimi
that Sandcastle bass or everybody babe
ass dude put that thing back in its
mother
hey little fish where'd you go
Petsmart feel disrespected get some glue
and put that thing back in his shell but
would you catch with your bare hand I'll
show you the world
I caught it on see how'd you get you
would you catch it on just a whistle
just say I caught it on to watch the
lower piece of candy there you go dick
dick it's a ghost rose gold oh wow oh I
love the rose gold fish is like that
little [ __ ] in the water
yeah but moves really yes that's your
go-to huh oh my go to glitter [ __ ] and
that King and the sting merge hit right
there yep yeah it's beautiful you don't
see the back of you might catch a 310
pound land bag sashimi
it's a chamois bra y'all need a tight
knit and look at care about the sell out
of that [ __ ] now where's that yeah let
me see the back at that thing oh yeah
who's in the community do we we've never
done that dude never and cheers we're
all going to jail from this podcast
but now look skew does it feel nice yeah
it's nice it's great it's cozy what size
is that I say small well you lose a
white man I got this hitter I get
stressed and then you don't sleep it's
cool man
and I'm sporting that mic Clevenger
hitter right here shoutout Cleveland do
you look like a DJ at a car wash all
right everybody's not less red all right
guys we're gonna do the hubcaps
all right we're gonna do the hook calves
guys man I'm feeling alive brother you
look alive man throw I've been going on
the road a little more I'm in San
Antonio this week and I went dude how am
I gonna cover my nutritional base dude
say how am I gonna do I gotta stay
healthy gotta stay greeny dawg and what
do you do are you doing like a growing a
garden in each city where you go or you
know I thought about that and I looked
at the logistics it's just too much and
then athletic greens came along said yo
man we got the ultimate daily all-in-one
health drink 75 vitamins for your stupid
thick mouth all right the most complete
sub went for a better you oh we're
feeling sick on the road anymore man
athletic greens includes prebiotics
probiotics digestive enzymes superfoods
one-stop shop to help support your
body's nutritional needs across five
critical areas of health including
energy immunity gut health quit having
that nasty guts talking to somebody in
your guts all nasty right hormonal and
neural support and it helps you age
healthily I'm how do you got through
that neural support thank you brother it
was a tough one it was yeah it's
definitely got a few hills in it man and
I'll say this though man athletic greens
bro this shouldn't make you athletic if
you're not athletic bruh drink this [ __ ]
to play hockey do skateboard and do
something you'd feel better perform
your best everyday with you're an
athlete taking steps for healthier
lifestyle whatever it is just be
healthier man athletic greens takes the
guesswork out of everyday good health
why not just try it we got a deal for
you athletic greens calm / K 80s and
claim our special offer today 20 free
travel packs valued at $79 with your
first purchase that's the free part so
you make a purchase and you get that 20
free travel packs valued at 79 bucks
athletic greens calm / K 80s hello fresh
oh dang that your new rapper name hello
fresh I wish dog yeah that's my new chef
name I'm talking delicious hello fresh
recipe with every sipes baby sob dog yet
I will say this man sometimes I don't
want to I don't want to cook but I want
to but I want to cook then do it with
hello fresh save time and dude it's so
effortless did you just make this stuff
most of its made under 30 minutes
sometimes even 20 minutes you can save
up to 28% by using hello fresh versus
your grocery store save money he
delicious right it's flex will fit your
lifestyle whatever it is man whatever
diet you're on they got you and also
hellofresh is committed to giving back
mm-hmm hello fresh donate over 2.5
million meals have chaired into our 1900
and yeah and look I'll say this if you
want to do like a date night at the
house or you want to do a family time
are you and the child or children more
than one child want to do a meal
together make a meal talk about family
meal yeah put a little put a little bit
put a little move a little song on the
phone put a little effort of my effort I
mean 30 20 minutes and your kids at
makeout day use that Wolfgang Puck yeah
put a song on the phone and then enjoy
it put a little jazz on and make
something with your lady that's the
beautiful thing about these the meal
it's right there the directions it's all
organized but it's still fun it's still
you're enjoying yourself while you do it
and right now you can go to hellofresh
calm slash 6 0 K 80s and use code 6 0 K
80s to get
sixty dollars off your first three weeks
including free shipping on your first
box additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh comm for more details
hellofresh comm / 6-0 ka TS y'all really
gotta help me come up with a Barbie you
get first of all you got to make a
decent sauce man so I would learn I mean
this is just my suggestions and so it
starts with the sauce there I am right
there shout out one of my primo tic TOCs
all over the car
oh yeah that's a fantastic shirt
why use all wet we can come off the wall
you know whatever that's America breath
I guess the audio doesn't good we can't
hear it
damn Nick was doing so well - we I'm not
giving a bonus - now one more dude chins
can take control the [ __ ] I remember I
can't even barely see Nick when I look
over there now to see chin see tan - I
don't know beautiful dude mr steal yo
fish did your girl go fishing with you
chin yeah she's gonna set it up oh she
likes it
she's she loves it oh that's wifey
something for you that's wifey you know
it might be time to seem about put a
little lure on her finger yeah that perm
alert the only word in for like you know
five months been friends forever change
that's true yeah that's true you told
our poor friend haha Carl you're married
how she and by the way she and she a
like whoa bro back off dude okay I'm
sorry chin has a couple of drinks and
admit that he's actually a grandparent
couple sake shots on the cities of
father for drinks yes the longer history
has going on squat knees do some Korean
barbecue we go now what if you guys
combine made a nice Korean barbecue you
can do something Korean you know smoking
[Laughter]
I never logged in I have never logged in
gianni has control of the account so if
there's anything going on through that
same Oh Jionni's gonna go to jail
[Laughter]
anything ever
that's all Gianni man there he is and
there he is yeah let's put a pitch right
there there yeah okay
lazy the stiffest model in the world
wozy lost right there outside of a
island's restaurant that makes me not
want to buy that shirt we gotta keep
going though he looks like Brian Austin
grown he doesn't bro he's a young guy
he's forty seventeen or thirty or
something he's 24 man
Oh daddy you would beat his ass well I'd
let him cut my arm for about 30 seconds
meet him at five - OH
Johnny's a handsome guy he just
definitely plays it to a distinct level
yeah relax man
some of them are like pictures you at
see if somebody had a funeral the one
that they would like the one him with
his lip like what is why would you post
them happy Friday everyone
oh I think he had a mole here uh not a
moment like something happen at the get
up like a contusion or something used to
covering up but yeah that's a weird way
to do just close your mouth up his
Instagram is weird cuz he's actually
like hilarious on tik-tok he's got this
Rhode Island dad who like threatens to
beat the [ __ ] out of him and his
brothers it's it's a good time Oh Tom
he's a great dude some of his fit this
other one now look at this one detective
on the left he looks like Inspector
Gadget little troubled son like
Inspector tragic bro but see look at him
with Bobby Lee now you look it that's
how he is he's just he's like regular
and fun he's got a new arm and look at
oh there he is he loves Bobby Lee and
he's got a new picture he's got a new
show coming up called Book of Mormon -
or something power book - ghost
it's the spin-off of power it's 50 cent
show he's one of the leads oh you were
way off well [ __ ] I mean the title is 40
words in it
terrible time PowerBook and 52 ghosts
sounds like a shitty mission applause
not like something you get at a Best Buy
dude near there near the front who's
gonna be able to pronounce it but
obviously we wish him the best of luck
that's good band gift for him booking
that [ __ ] that he's going on you know
dude
nothing not much I'm head to San Antonio
Thursday back on the road real exes
might look at some houses one mount
Hamnet Santana now I'm gonna drive up to
Austin so about 45 minutes I think it's
beautiful over there
you know Texas beautiful man love it man
that's about it
go dark you hopefully baseball comes
back to remind me of that and if they do
60 games I think it'd make it more
exciting cuz that's like all the games
count so it'd be so exciting just a 660
games
and imagine if they were all baseball
like baseball's kind of one say it's
lost some of its a lure but I know it
has that's fine to say it's not
America's pastime anymore yeah football
runs America yeah football so I just
think they could pick up a lot of fans
in a lot of excitement right now else is
going on yeah it's almost like just bite
the budget or whatever it is which is
what they're doing yeah because some of
the big teams that make all the money
they don't want to I guess they don't
want to but they agreed to it so baby
yeah July dry I think 24th it's gonna
start shout out man yeah my Clevenger
sent me these jersey unwashed he want to
think 7 or 11 or 12 games and I love
baseball jerseys but when you do a king
of sting baseball jersey yeah we had one
yeah
well that but that was like that was a
Jersey but I'm talking like you should
say you know like it look right well
official sewn in something on the back
will do something good oh that meet me
at 240 picture looks today dude was that
your idea the double dragon no dude I
thought it was I was gonna say yes crazy
almost L the hardest gave you credit is
that double dragon cuz I mean my brother
a huge fan that he was it is Theos idea
oh wow so maybe set it you just forgot
yeah oh
a CT flare another bang
don't touch me anymore for real
the guys like if CT is start seems like
a starting your knuckles so let's put
this thing out there let him bite on it
well I'll tell you what man you want to
make some money listen
Knicks pics on UFC Betsy assembly his
bets begin it I when I sent him my pics
I I was 4 4 5 and up $1600 I ended up to
do I ended up winning 1200 because I I
was drinking that now you got a little
crazy dollars on Keith Peters I thought
Curtis blades would get the under I
thought he was just gonna smash him but
I was gonna finish em hmm
come on son oh yes worth MMA betting's
like my gym yeah I mean Mattia it's what
a laugh Nick basically sleeping in here
in about a year sorry about that
[Laughter]
Yancy apparently if you want to catch it
if you want to catch a cat that's what
you got a fish on you got a fish on
those legitimate me undies man dude
sometimes I you know I ordered something
the other day and I I don't even know if
I got it it was a how do it was like it
was a how to dab at home oh dude that's
cuz they're not shipping with the right
people I'm talking about ship station
whatever you're selling oh I'll tell you
what else ordered I ordered a um like a
rare horn like an animal horn it took
forever to get there it hasn't come came
and track it dude you need ship station
whatever you're selling horn oh I'll
tell you what else it is oh dude I got a
um one of those um it's like a water
moccasin ding come ahead and come dude
and now I'm alarmed because I'm calling
a post office a na be careful this
should use shipstation man that's why
you need ship station calm the fastest
easiest and most affordable or ders
whether it's horns or water moccasins
whatever it is it's so dang easy to use
printout labels get your product to
happy customers like Theo von ship
station makes it easy ship station help
sellers of any size get orders out
quickly save money on shipping costs
keep your customers happy
no matter what you're selling Amazon
Etsy your own website shipstation brings
you all the orders one simple interface
up you can manage them easily from your
computer or from any device even your
cell phone and right now our listeners
can try ship station for free for 60
days when you use offer code k ATS make
sure your business is ready to meet the
demands of delivery culture get started
at ship station calm today click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
typing K 80s that ship station comm then
enter the code k 80s ship station calm
make ship happen let's get into this
jeeps here's a first this was a relevant
debate club cos L Brennan coming we're
open
oh my god you're so good this you should
be like one of those whatever it is or
good you can draw suspects out at a
police station yeah
looks like John Legend cops like right
thanks man
don't he look like Whoville uh yeah you
look after you
thank you apparently and there's an
off-ramp from Wisconsin straight to
fricken knob to Whoville he also looks
like Jionni if he had stayed in school
and not dropped out early to play hockey
and Mogadishu whoever Johnny fight also
played hockey and Mogadishu or something
buddy so what's his question hunting or
fishing listen man you know I have some
ar-15s myself just for because the
world's on fire you never know who's
gonna try breaking their house stealing
your kids but I can't can't shoot
animals man it's just not my bag baby I
can't shoot animals I feel bad for him I
think deer cute is [ __ ]
I even like warthogs this time I went
hunting one time in Hawaii once they
showed me these baby warthogs I start
being real loud just to alert the
warthogs that were coming that's the
first time they ever went on a trip and
didn't kill a warthog which was a win
for me I think I can't kill animals
Brendan wore a wind chime on his shirt
you don't need a we're wint I'm just
your breathing is yeah I can't kill
animals fishing all day I no remorse
when it comes to fish Wow
I think I've always said I'm down to
kill an animal if you do it with your
bare hands
yeah or a knife if you go out boar you
get two knifes and go out against a boar
you get some silverware and go out
against a boar that's meas fair it's
more fair I like hunting with [ __ ]
you know they got the lasers on them and
the heat-seeking [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
not teeth that's not how it's supposed
to go down kill that [ __ ] with an arrow
became Hanes dog yeah cam handy hunt
down mountain side of mountains his boy
died falling off the mountain hunting
goat no way yeah dog do real [ __ ] yeah I
think I and I love a little bit of goat
man I don't if you've ever had good or
not no you haven't
oh do the back strap off a [ __ ]
little belly brawl eat that [ __ ] all
day that Billy jerky into a soup yeah
I'll eat that little hamstring soup oh
my god
it's good you know I talk all this [ __ ]
on my boys side
I'd be down to do it once well I think
they I just want to see more legit style
hunting I want real [ __ ] I want to see
people go out there I would watch a man
hunt all day if he's going out there
with a body cam on and two knifes and
he's gonna fight a boar I think go on
like search for them yeah but their dogs
do it the dogs like are mangling things
and they shoot it or they go they won
Hawaii that the dogs go up and like flip
it on its back and the dog have its neck
and then they go up with a knife and
stab it no [ __ ] that I'm talking I'm
with y'all just fine like no they they
attack it I'm talking being real quiet
wearing cuff covering your shoes in
cotton and getting a couple knifes I
mean like yeah maybe a sword and get out
there and hunt that [ __ ] and find it
I'm talking about I'm talking a wooden
[ __ ] bow and arrow yeah boys they got
home ya know I'm talking about your kids
sleeping by a fire yeah I'm talking
about real [ __ ] let's see what this
young fellas gotta say now here's a guy
who did it
Brice Mitchell choked the deer out oh
yeah there's a deer taking a nap he
snuck up on him and I said I'm talking
about exactly what I'm talking about
he literally said he put it in a rear
naked choke and he choked it out for
about six minutes and right took forever
he said it took a long time dude he said
that he remember he did say that he
watched an episode of Big Bang Theory on
his phone season 3 of lost and killed
this poor dear it took a while Shan you
hunt though right I've never been
hunting I want to do it once just like
you guys these two I just wanna do it
once because we meet all the time right
Tim Kelly asked me all the time to go
with him Ken Haynes that's me go with
them you have I passed people to go I I
know Steve Rinella soon I'd be down to
hunt it was like something dangerous
they're like hey there's this man-eating
tiger dude and we got to find
that sounds fun but if it's we're gonna
hunt some little white-tailed deer
I'm not into that you know y'all gay man
yeah some people are just trying to be
gay - dude yeah I'm dude sleep with the
buddies out in the woods yeah somebody
take you hunting in it's just at a motel
6 somewhere yeah
hey man when we get out there start
looking for animals ah dude let's just
chilling yeah yeah let's order in and
you're like well you have a six pack of
monster do you know chubby uh Paul
here's a young fella right here who's
Evans going through some ministers and
tells us a little bit what's good gang
game buzz buzz scissor hope y'all are
doing well during these quarantine times
I gotta gotta got the debate club for
you hot testicular for you training day
training day or bad boys which one you
guys going with Denzel or Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence both classics both
awesome
I'd love for both of y'all shall watch
your videos on the 1 to 49 as I loved
your coverage bra do your podcast help
me through some dark times brother cuz I
do take you out yeah a lot of problems
with you know you know the dark arts
theater maybe yeah - keep pushing guys
watch the game game buzz buzz good luck
with everything
his Energy's through the room his email
this guy's name is Shawn and his email
with Celtic rage that dudes fighting
some deem is done or Celtic rage again
yeah that dude from the 12th round with
some [ __ ] demons I think he's going
30 rounds with pure Pharma
what's up showing man I appreciate the
message bro thanks for getting in touch
with us yeah we love you man we're
making jokes where we love you think
seanny good luck fighting them [ __ ]
demons dude yeah dude
everybody's got a man and all what um
what was the I asking about training
I'll do trained it when Denzel gets in
that [ __ ] El Camino and little Ethan
Hawke's like where's your office you win
the office dude legendary bro dr. Dre
yeah it was so fire like movies baby
he's right drinking carrot juice and
[ __ ] right now novel or sums and I
can't wait to read it
yeah real smart man yeah he's an
interesting dude yeah I'm a fan too yeah
hell yeah
trained a 56% yeah mm-hmm that boys is
good but nothing bad boys is like fun
training days like that gritty oh do
train day is that real [ __ ] and here's a
fellow up here and this looks like it's
an organ and shout-out to this guy for
recording his video and landscape
horizontally that's preferred okay what
up seal what a branded debate club
big spoon verse little spoon personally
modern feminist I'm okay with being that
little spoon hitter wearing that female
like a backpack let me know what you
think gang gang but Snuggs nuts - but
bro I like being the big spoon man I'm
old school
yeah feel real weird being the little
spoon you know yeah I like me in a moan
silverware drawer really honest I really
do
I like making sure that the other person
is happy and has a bed and a place to
sleep and then I like to sleep in Moscow
like to be that single spoon yeah I like
to be in the dishwasher yeah what about
you can't what's going on from the
woman's perspective um
well from my experience the tougher a
guy tries to act out in public he loves
being a little spoon in private yeah and
then it's the reverse of a guy's kind of
chill he's cool being a big spoon Wow
hmm I feel like cats can date a guy
where they hear a noise might check it
out can you go check it out go see what
that was like y'all go see what it was
hopefully it's a [ __ ] tougher man
than you
[Laughter]
Chappelle what do you think run I love
you like throw these softballs up to
Chappelle man strikes out dude I love it
I get so excited she was texting little
spoon
that's what I'm talking about anger
issues wanna be a little yeah Nick you
got a girl you trying to snuggle up you
so I like back i like being big spoon
when we're cuddling but when it's time
to go to sleep i need to turn over and
if she wants to drape or arm around me
that's fine like III like it like we can
we can touch but like I gotta go to
sleep so like I can't fall asleep yeah
that's not your space for kids yeah high
school kids that are dating each other
and that know each other well in the but
they're both 15 yeah yeah clear yeah we
my girlfriend wanted to experiment being
the big spoon oh yeah bro it was my bird
it was my birthday my girl got real
freaky man she decided I was gonna be
the little spoon and talk a bunch of
[ __ ] man I gotta let her do it I let
her do it she wanted to do it so I let
her do it and then she liked it but I
was like it didn't feel right so I'm
always the big spoon yeah it just
doesn't feel normal doesn't feel right
it's got that yeah I think maybe if it's
a if it's for warmth or something like
that maybe or you're stuck trapped
somewhere outside you got locked out of
the house or something off to sleep
outside yeah if it's like a [ __ ] I'm
afraid situation then we're going to
tease the back you feel me I'm yeah stay
warm wear it like a blanket but a normal
house got dude I need my space I'm not
trying to be no spoon I'm with you on
this I want my own bedroom on my own
bathroom me to do I'm not trying to hold
a fart in all night either
come on no dude I used to date this card
to go fart on the balcony sometimes I do
this I do the silencer I put that
[ __ ] pillow to my ass someone pinkeye
dude maybe maybe the old silencer dude
the classic move do
when I first yes I live in a studio in
Rio Del Rio lived in a studio in the
bathroom it was tiny the bathrooms like
next to right next to the [ __ ]
bedroom
dude I was dating this girl she went in
and blew that [ __ ]
yeah there's no silence in that Oh Oh
God
disturbing dude yeah dude every time I
hear a girl fart or something just part
of me died it'll ruin your day bro one
bedroom studio some girl blows that
starts playing them toilet trumpets next
to your bad dude bro I remember one time
I was high on drugs and I was in England
actually somewhere in England and uh and
I saved this girl's place and I thought
she'd fallen asleep so I went to the
bathroom to do number two do a stool
sure and sometimes just got it good and
so I'm in there for like 40 minutes
doing there like British literature and
stuff I'm reading up you know yeah
getting to know you know getting
familiar with the continent or whatever
yeah and and I come out and she'd been
awake the whole time I thought you know
I've been by myself in her bathroom for
40 minutes like I had shapee you know oh
there was a line you know when I do it I
used to I used to run the shower well I
run the shower man cuz then you got this
you have hide the smell and [ __ ] it's
exhausting you're wasting water brothers
people in countries they don't have any
water
hey man you've been water to mask a
stool whatever it takes
all right I was about to turn into that
Kimbo Slice joke again if you didn't
come on what else you got in there
yeah Nick first of all we danced to that
one guy I don't think I don't we answer
bhikshu in the spoon I said big split
all Dylan shoot fish no we took that
[ __ ] racing fishing pretty much unless
you unless you're going barehanded yeah
respect respect this was actually
doesn't really fit in a category but
something notice very someone noticed
something very interesting on the latest
episode of queer eye or a
so if we write hey guys this is Vivian
Joe and Burbank we were just watching
the queer eye and we heard something
familiar see ya Musa theme song queer
eye were they yeah yeah I don't know
what this happened I know what's going
on that lady likes it can they use it
queer eye they used our theme song wow
that's crazy man our gay fans must love
that all four of them know there's a lot
of meaning in it oh you know since we
had a chip held in - yeah there you go
that's a great yeah oh yeah and now a
lotta I want to bring this up though to
use Chappelle a lot of cheerleaders used
also performance-enhancing drugs
is that true yeah yeah that's fair yeah
that'd be performance-enhancing so yeah
and how much Hardy hit a backflip on
some decades-- yeah but magic trial I
know
imagine the cartwheels you perform on
winstram I know B go from good to great
go to great run great you start a
backflip on a Monday who knows man I
wanna be surprised yes yeah LeBron James
yeah not a good Mormon he's too old dog
to be perform at that level and the
injury's time on HGH spraying some [ __ ]
LeBron got real skinny and shredded come
on son really go I'm vegan I'm biking
yay you ain't bike and biking biking to
the store yeah my ain't put no big-boy
videos up like you nope ain't doing that
you're right all right okay what else
you got Nick I can't believe that
they're watching that on that listening
right now she was getting down to she
was huh yeah
she wanted that broccolini dude stop
Doug you need to have some side items to
at your barbecue yeah you need some I
smashed a small bass maybe chin small
bass
Chin's bass Nuggets you know they're all
tiny side of candy canes little tiny
very last debate club what's up guys
Nathan from Chicago I'm half Vietnamese
so I need this debate question answered
cat is Vietnamese and chin is Korean
which is better Vietnamese or Korean
food gang gang buzz-buzz I know the
answer I'll let you guys say which
people are better which food is better
which food
we said food I thought I said people to
on my damn Doug first I bet they don't
even know Vietnamese cuisine no I can
tell you a dish you guys know one for
sure what's the most popular but I hate
fun that's not a meal soups not a
[ __ ] me when people go you want to
get fat nah dude I'm a big spoon and I'm
a grown man
I'm like an eat soup for a [ __ ] meal
we just lost half her size so it is a
meal for us
ya know imagine being a soul it just be
enough semi not extremely hided kind of
human running around busy have to get
back to school quit yeah yeah and then
what's the what's what's the other dish
what would it would Korean food cream
elf Korean bar yeah right come on I've
only had Korean barbecue once but I
definitely like it more than [ __ ] and
you went to a really bad place you don't
like any more than chin though what you
know something we went to or the worst
possible place watch our team got to
Washington LA at least the place I
talked Dukey and sting needs to go man
yeah that'd be dope yeah we could do we
should do obviously some Korean joint
and he took me to a bathhouse after but
they do you know we spa huh it was
something I've been to we spa a bunch
was like this hidden one I was like hey
he's like he just pulled up and like you
know stopped his car and I was he was
like we doing this and I was like it's
got a jimjilbang I don't know it was
hidden it was like you don't know it's
there yeah and you wear robes sometimes
no they were not roll sometimes yeah I
went to we spot what guess found out
it's like does some people can wear some
trunks dude everybody naked up in the or
that yeah they're little dicks in your
face we don't eat it no we don't need it
he was doing karate kicks in the sauna
and he doesn't have a lot of muscles in
his body Bobby he's mostly heartless
yeah yeah he's Cartledge and not even a
lot of bone you know you could fill his
whole leg and not find a bone in it he's
like Gumby
you got that very unique body type that
kind of dots you ever seen those stuff
dots at the movies when you get that
futuristic ice cream oh yeah oh I love
those yeah he's got a lot of kind of
like that's a lot of bobbies I'm gonna
go with Korean foods better mm-hmm but I
don't know about Vietnamese and Korean
would you would one of you guys rather
be the other ethnicity no not me Wow I'm
very prideful we should try some instead
of burgers see here's the thing though
Jeff why should is very it's an acquired
taste not a lot of people are willing to
eat fish sauce even you're going Korean
food it sounds like no I love it I love
it nummies food I just know for like if
you're not Asian it's kind of hard for
you to eat how fans asked us to try
other food on this I haven't seen we
should do a spicy one I'll tell you this
story so I was at Shanghai mm-hmm and
that could be in one of you guys is my
knees and there we go and I also met a
man who was Taiwanese this weekend and
he said [ __ ] the Chinese he told me yep
oh they hate the Tran I said look no let
me get my globe out of the trunk before
I get into this but um I remember they
had a breakfast bar at this hotel and
they had one half was American and one
half was Chinese or Asian food
and it was strikingly different like I
went on the asian side and it was just a
total like and it was breakfast and I'm
like this is breakfast is a bunch of
different options oh they had like a
little like I don't even know some of it
was a lot of fish dried out fish a lot
of like stuff that seemed like flakes a
lot of vegetables a lot of like stuff
you would see like kind of by the beach
a little bit Chinese or bigger people
though right
compared to Koreans and Koreans are
probably the biggest actual size people
yeah the biggest
I feel like Chinese you can't even hide
a Korean you're just mean just yell me
Jeremy anomaly those are anomalies all
right
well change the a giant Korean they're
bigger than me now yummy not read like
literally they found the two tallest
because he was already fish recreated in
the lab yeah um but anyway so yeah I
just think the food the world the food
world like you're saying with fish sauce
or whatever the food worlds are totally
very different you know what they might
like that is a the bonhomie the barbecue
one talk about national barbecue
delicious barbecue meat bother me yeah I
think they would actually dig that what
ramens what Japanese we should just
bring stuff in and see what you guys
like better
well you trying to bring them below
remember that was yeah it's like embryo
you ate that bird yeah yeah I had some I
saw it I threw up well also chin didn't
cook it that was a mistake I thought
they were cooked already so when they
opened it was wrong bro that is okay
sorcery is dead movie is covered in
blood I didn't want to try it yeah you
should have tried it you've gotten sick
get sick dude I hate couple hits of it
man
let's see what else you got it's a
unique I would you know they don't have
it at Shoney's I'll say that I just put
this one up at the beginning of the
episode a bunch of [ __ ] marvel
Jamia itches much a tough women orto
flame look at that Wow yeah that's 57%
safe Korean food that's interesting man
yeah I think I just think I don't have
enough experience with the two foods so
I will probably need to go to some
restaurants will bring it will bring
something I think they like curry I
think you guys would like Korean food
more you never know any excuse to wear
those glasses again yeah you can just
eat dishes save it yeah yeah yeah but we
get which one we like better than huh
I'll tell you what it is but put in
Chinese Korean and no Chinese - no no no
no dude from the mall it tastes like you
have to buy shoes in a few minutes I
post mates panda time I'll get a large
entree only orange you know you
shouldn't your pants and I oh do double
the double scoop orange chicken you
talking about that sugar chicken dog I
feel so bad about myself after I do eat
or shaking I [ __ ] punch myself I'm so
disappointed myself dog and that's in
Keith Petersen says hey man let's just
go on a little walk so I've seen a lot
of people asking for like to flaunt my
odds chide my rides all that but we need
videos don't just send in a picture or
and send it and for tried my ride don't
send in a picture of a car you seen on a
street it's gotta be your car so this is
a chide my ride alright hey boys I'm
here to show off my ride this is a 2007
Freightliner packaged car gang
and it comes stuck with this nice
diamond plate floor that's it hey I'm in
Stu's my fridge
that's aftermarket though pay for that
myself
I feel like this man's living out of
this car also aftermarket this one's
pretty young she's only got 400,000
miles on nothing like when you're
waiting for a pack as you see that Brown
[ __ ] hit or pull up like oh hell yeah
here he comes put on some Cologne
that's a beautiful rod man that's really
this that every day Santa Claus right
there doing the Lord's work one package
at a time he said [ __ ] Amazon and
it's interesting to seeing how like yeah
you got a you bring your own stuff that
thing's pretty basic huh I think it's
just pretty run-of-the-mill did he say I
have his own radio in there yeah so you
bought all the aftermarket starter so
that's wild man thanks for being out
there bro on the front lines dude so
people can't [ __ ] you know stuff yeah
close out with a king under sting it CEO
Brendan Chan Nick cat mr. Lacey what's
good it's a beautiful day in West
Virginia I'm talking Charleston West my
god Virginia beautiful
do you King or do you sting the idea
about being on one of these flights
future flights that are gonna
potentially colonize Mars do you king or
do sting its I hear that Mars rides are
just one way ain't coming back so
appreciate you guys Podcast rocks Gang
Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz mr. blue eyes
[ __ ] Austin well Mars same thing like
I'm doing with us and I'm we go ahead
and let broke and go out there first
tell me the lay of the land then I'll
follow up you feel me Brogan's can go to
Mars go ahead you have to admit there's
no doubt that Rogan would go to Mars if
they got any way to do it
oh I might get a text like hey Doug
change the plans I went decide to go to
Mars
alright hey real quick I bought Mars so
we're doing the common stir when Mars
man you down you have to get your boron
levels check should be cool man I got I
hired a doctor this dude said a bust and
Timberlake over here and so we get him a
boyband
check out them brows - this guy is mixed
it's the most light-skinned black dude
I've ever even seen do you want to be
the little spoon he also talked for like
three minutes trying to convince you
guys to come to Nashville so the master
yeah I just made it shorter but yeah
he's just like we're open we got comedy
in Nashville yeah but he's in West
Virginia I thought but he does real
estate I guess maybe I don't know maybe
he talked for something about for three
minutes I don't know I cut it off but
okay
someone was convincing us to go in
Nashville said no state income tax and
stuff yeah he's right I'm gonna look in
a couple weeks over there I think we'll
just get together and do King the sting
yeah
figure it out
so yeah I think it'd be cool I just yeah
someone I think I don't know if I can be
in this place anymore sometimes it just
feels brother tough it's just scary yeah
I don't know about all going to Mars
[ __ ] that noise yeah yeah but again I
could be talked into it
well this young man was asking about um
what's the taxes like on Mars you feel
me I'm bad high as hell yeah build a
[ __ ] society yeah
well that one man did it any but them
vegetables member Matt Damon good point
you know those dope ass SUVs and [ __ ]
rolling around Mars
they took his own [ __ ] made potatoes out
of it that was cool and then he won the
Golden Globe for Best Comedy for that
drama slow year but yeah a wee little
for Dakar on Mars Rogen but it won't be
the only way to borrow the car from him
oh yeah we have like just an uber day
he'd be our uber driver yeah be like a
140 million dollar vehicle it'd be it'd
be him and Elon Musk Rover by Tesla yeah
yeah tell me boring as [ __ ] over there
after a while it'd be cool for a - I bet
three days bro by day four I'd be like
oh I'll go anywhere that's fair you know
I bet it would just get cuz you're all
gonna be in the same little place you're
not gonna have a big place on Mars
probably cuz I bet it the square
footages can't be cheap half a mil per
foot you know no restaurants that's why
you'd open up the barbecue spot on Mars
yeah out of this world Lacey do your
recipes no gravity said do your recipes
need gravity bro that's the first thing
you gotta bring a lot of sugar with you
yeah where are you gonna get the ribs
yes good you got a deer it something
that's been living here we don't know
what the wildlife is like up there yeah
bro you don't have any plan I'm not
invested in this BBQ joint anymore I'm
gonna reopen that email about that
Sinaloa zoo we got says
that's a good real tasty right now yeah
that looks like a better business
opportunity Chappell yeah now what if
you had a barbecue truck done member
that's rug but if you did a truck you
know no you can promote on food truck
Diaries and that has to be pretty fire
food though you can't put the car before
the truck yeah just can't have anyone on
the show man there's two ways to get on
that show you either buy the truck or
you fight that guy that Brendan
[Laughter]
mr. Larkin or whatever Justin there John
occurred fight Johnny Curtis you get on
the show huh yourself man God YouTube is
gonna be your trainer Doug YouTube is my
trainer oh my god I mean YouTube what
was this guy's question I can you
remember colonizing Mars king under
stinging well Mustaine yeah I don't stop
there forever no it still might be
better in LA right now do they have a
Korean space program as Korea has made
for me yeah no I don't they don't I have
no idea oh so I didn't know if you
governor [ __ ] newsome's gonna be up
there as well you know what it seemed
like space cuz it's awesome Russia to
America right isn't it interesting you
know it's such a is it like oh do you
think it's been like a white thing
trying to get to space cuz it's
interesting that other countries are
like dude this is [ __ ] like y'all
have smart I don't know 101 things to go
to like a different countries like I
want to go to Manchester yeah well buy a
ticket we talked about Mars lacy came to
get a [ __ ] together for the food truck
yeah you can make a shitty barbecue
sauce Union million ideas here man [ __ ]
space for you Chappelle's you like man
everybody what's going to bar gonna go
to Manchester everybody trying it to
Mars I'm trying to go to Burbank Allah
knows Mars King it people want to go
yeah people are feeling it [ __ ] go then
you know I thought it was interesting
Louie keys in louis c.k special the new
one that's on just on the internet it's
great he talks about he's like yeah and
you know i just i had a lot of bad
publicity going on and i wanted to go
somewhere he goes the problem is you
every place you pick is still on earth
he goes he goes I really wanted to go to
another planet he's like I literally
remember getting on the internet and
thinking man is there anybody that can't
just go to another planet he's been
watching too much Rick and Morty [ __ ]
yeah yeah story was shitty toons
oh well oh well shout-out to Manchester
hopefully I get there one day
I don't know what will happen hopefully
they'll build ways that we get there
yeah well tell me Tom tell red wonder
how the people over there oh did you do
comedy out there Chappelle I don't know
dude no be a pioneer yeah
do you be a pioneer bro Lewis and Clark
man get outta the Columbus of Manchester
Doug but I'll be the Chappelle they see
of Manchester yeah you gotta buy ticket
yeah pray on it bro pray on it yeah see
if he maybe they'll do some kind of
thing where people could you know start
out in one place and end up in another
somehow via some method via flight or
water yes I'm not crazy Nick but yeah
yeah something like that
I was thinking prayer mostly yeah maybe
they'll find some way yeah then maybe
the creating apps again like judge it
you know
yeah like Yelp or so well zip man we got
new merged cat shop calm and get this
soft tailor there and we might even sell
cats been keeping this one warm we'll
put that one on there first one on there
included What's Up daddy get them wide
because I know trying to be that little
spoon nah man I'm not get you get so
much was it cat shop yep cat shop calm
son get it yep thank you guys so much
man yeah thank you for telling it man
the show's never been bigger for
whatever reason starting to gain our
stride here yeah yeah thank everybody
cat Chappelle Nick bring all the work
man Colin helps a lot in the bag people
been asking who that is in the back
there
Kyle's been putting on weight as well
looks fun just some people have some
idea who he is and what's going on with
it
yeah he could be your barbecue he could
be the first victim huh yeah just be
happy with Paul wall baby Paul wall
invest in your barbecue baby yeah
sitting sideways Oh sitting sideways
barbecue sun-sin sideways barbecue chef
good luck we love you guys Brennan and
Theo fighter and wait I gotta go in and
go hard in the paint I do not think I am
in flow black rifle coffee I'm ready to
go
the sponsor I am a monster about to open
up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls letter Instagram famous damn
I'll be like I'm fresh off keto see a
red like Andrew Santino every Sunday is
like the great Bambino in an eight the
case oh and the case Cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine
hate on me I do not mind got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
try to couldn't beat him
quit playing like that's in DoDEA's you
don't want the smoke like Joey Diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and I'm feeling
incredible Brit and Sun him me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up a sting King and
and the sting bee sting Rat King
in a stinking honesty
trap gotta she's gonna strangle her in
the sting King in the stinking in the
sting bee sting Rat King
and the sting a king and a sting got a
phase in the track got that cheese on a
strong
[Music]